Marvel Studios' "Loki" has introduced a whole
new variant on everyone's favorite god of
mischief.
With the mysterious Sylvie running around
the timeline with Loki in tow, the MCU is
getting weirder than it's ever been before.
Here are the Easter eggs you missed in "Loki"
episode 3.
Much of "Loki" Episode 3 is spent on Lamentis-1,
a rocky, purple-skied moon facing imminent
destruction.
The episode is even named after Lamentis,
which has briefly appeared in Marvel Comics.
Debuting in 2007's "Annihilation: Conquest
Prologue" #1, it lies on the outskirts of
Kree space.
That appearance is basically just a mention,
which means that for all intents and purposes,
Lamentis-1 is basically a blank slate for
the Marvel Cinematic Universe - a perfect
spot for "Loki" to continue delving into its
narrative mysteries, in other words.
Loki and Sylvie arrive on Lamentis-1 after
escaping from Ravonna and her Minutemen following
a skirmish outside the elevator doors leading
to the Time Keepers.
They land on the moon in 2077, 12 hours before
it's set to collide with its planet - an inconvenient
apocalypse for them to hide in, but with their
TemPad low on juice, this odd couple of Lokis
is forced to make the best of a bad situation.
"I'm not the only tech-savvy Loki."
"Don't ever call me that."
"Tech-savvy?"
"No, a Loki."
After Sylvie and Loki sneak on board the shuttle
ferrying ticket-holders off Lamentis-1, they
have time to start getting to know one another
- so naturally, talk turns to their love lives.
Sylvie remains as cagey as ever, but tells
Loki she's managed to keep a long-distance
relationship going with a "postman" as she
runs from one apocalypse to another.
"I've managed to maintain quite a serious
long-distance relationship with a postman
whilst running across time from one apocalypse
to another."
At first, this sounds like a joke - as if
she could maintain any kind of relationship
given her current life path - but as it turns
out, there's more than one Postman of note
in Marvel Comics that fans may know about.
First appearing in 2002's "Morlocks" #1, Postman
(a.k.a. David) is a mutant who lost control
of his powers and accidentally wiped his wife's
mind.
He seeks refuge with the Morlocks based in
Chicago and eventually becomes their leader.
Postman ends up losing his mutant abilities
thanks to the Scarlet Witch, whose "No More
Mutants" decree in 2005's "House of M" #7
wipes the mutant gene from the vast majority
of its carriers.
Of course, Sylvie and Postman don't appear
to have a clear connection in the comics,
so we'd say put a pin in this one.
It's not necessarily a hint that the Postman
character is coming, but across the movies
and TV shows of phase 4, the MCU is clearly
setting up something, and it'll be hard to
know what were real hints and what were just
coincidences until the series lays all its
cards on the table.
Multiverse?
Mutants?
Who knows.
Another famous postman is Willie Lumpkin,
the friendly mailman most known for his appearances
in the "Fantastic Four" comic books, and also
for dating May Parker in "The Amazing Spider-Man."
So who knows?
Maybe Sylvie had a thing for him.
There may look like there's a bit of an age
gap, but these are Lokis we're talking about.
Looks can be deceiving.
Or, maybe Sylvie really is just pining for
a hunky delivery man she's never been able
to settle down with.
It wouldn't be the first time an Asgardian
super-being has fallen for a regular Joe or
Jane.
We're treated to some fun callbacks to earlier
MCU chapters in "Loki," and Episode 3 is no
exception.
Once Loki and Sylvie work their way onto the
Lamentis shuttle, they sit and converse in
one of its upper-scale lounges.
As they talk, Loki helps himself to two glasses
of champagne, and Sylvie ends up falling asleep.
When she wakes, her new travel companion has
treated himself to more beverages, and he's
putting on a show for the other travelers
in the lounge.
After singing and giving cheers to Sylvie,
Loki smashes a martini glass and yells "Another!"
"Another!"
Loyal MCU fans will notice this nod to the
first "Thor" film - the line and gesture are
uttered by Thor when he visits a diner with
his new Earth pals Jane Foster, Erik Selvig,
and Darcy Lewis.
"This drink, I like it."
"I know, it's great right?"
"Another!"
The line is one of the most quoted from the
original "Thor" movie, which feels so long
ago at this point.
All of these characters have been through
so much at this point.
It's nice that the MCU can still slow down
and show that it remembers where it came from.
Check out one of our newest videos right here!
Plus, even more Looper videos about the Marvel
Cinematic Universe are coming soon.
Subscribe to our YouTube channel and hit the
bell so you don't miss a single one.